after 15 years he decided to come back
to stand up and make all of us so happy
why now why was it the perfect time
first of all thank you I don't know why
now I have no idea that it I didn't I
didn't plan it it was just kind of it
was suggested to me and I was like well
maybe so maybe that would be something
to to challenge me and I'll try to think
of something to talk about a friend of
mine was at my house and I told him I'm
gonna do stand-up again and he said well
do you think you're still relatable just
then but to my Butler stepped into the
library I made the deal before I had
anything to say and then once I made the
deal I panicked only like I think a year
and a half in started writing but almost
gave the money back twice and and then
all of a sudden it all hit me and I was
like oh my god this is I have something
to say and the name came to me and the
whole thing so but it's been it was
scary as hell
it was the perfect time obviously for
you to come back to do stand-up how are
you gonna know when it's the right time
to walk away from daytime um well I hope
I know when when people kind of are
tired of me
I think I'll sense that well yeah I mean
people get tired of people but and
especially in today's age I'll walk away
really when I when I stop having fun I
actually don't care about the rest of
the people if I if I'm having fun and no
one's watching I don't care but if I'm
if I'm not having fun and everyone's
watching
then I should walk away Kelly Clarkson
were so excited she's joining you in
daytime has she come to you for any
advice what have you told her um
yes she did she actually I'm not gonna
talk about that but I did give her
advice and I want her to succeed she's
my lead-in so and also she's my friend
so I wanted to succeed for many reasons
and we need more women out there doing
wonderful things so but I gave her some
advice and we'll see if she succeeds she
took my advice and if she doesn't
succeed she didn't and you're not gonna
tell us the advice no I just made that
up just now
[Music]